This cavernous building was
once an important landmark,
one full of fanfare,
competition, and celebration.
It's a building from
a different era,
not only in its vintage
look, but also in its spirit.
Berkeley Iceland was an
Olympic-sized ice rink
in Berkeley, California.
It is a unique place,
both in size and location,
sitting in the middle
of a quaint residential
neighborhood, making it a staple
to both the local community
and a national audience.
It opened its doors in
1940 and instantly became
an important destination.
It was a three-time host of
the US National Figure Skating
Championships, it was the
practice facility for the 1994
USA men's Olympic hockey
team, and it was also home
to numerous skating
clubs, birthday parties,
and teenage date nights.
But now, all that is gone.
Only memories are left.
Memories that may
not be replicated,
because places like this
just aren't built it anymore.
Empty lots are no longer
replaced with drive-ins,
roller rinks, or arcades.
These staples of different
eras are not reemerging.
They aren't showing up in new
developments or neighborhoods.
No longer will we see
an entire city block
dedicated to ice skating.
Instead we've made room for the
more practical or more modern.
These walls heard the voices of
Olympians talking about gold.
This sign glowed invitingly
to an entire community.
This is where people might
have met their future husbands
or wives.
Today it survives as a
testament to nostalgia,
a reminder of that
place where you grew up
that may have shaped your
life in some small way.
Berkeley Iceland is a fading
memory, but one with a happy
ending.
If you want to
explore an abandoned
city that was built to be
abandoned, click here now.
These walls were never
meant for family photos.
This is an abandoned town that
was built to be abandoned,
except for a few days every year
when it's a literal war zone.
And make sure to subscribe.
Seeker Stories puts a lot of
great videos out every week,
and subscribing is the
best way to make sure
that you see each new video.